I want to game out with you guys the
various possible outcomes for the 2020
election but I admit I'm sort of scared
to do this on the show because there
will be people in the audience who will
misunderstand what I'm doing either
deliberately or they will just
misunderstand it there will be people in
the audience who think about I am in
this segment going to suggest we support
someone other than a real progressive in
2020 and I want to be clear I'm doing
this segment because this is what we do
on the show this is the type of thing
that over the years people have come to
appreciate about the show we think about
things we consider possibilities we
discuss them but let me put this in
front of everything so that I am not
misunderstood we should vote for the
person whose values and policies most
closely match ours and I am a
progressive so I believe we should vote
for a progressive now that being said
that disclaimer given I want to game out
2020 with you let's imagine four basic
scenarios for 2020 think about it like a
2x2 grid on one side there's the
possibility that Democrats nominate
either a centrist or a progressive for
this example we could say Biden or
Bernie you could say clove azshara
Warren if you want to go by the New York
Times endorsements whatever the
Democrats could nominate a centrist or a
progressive along the other axis is the
possibility that Donald Trump either
wins re-election or loses it this gives
us four possible outcomes you could
nominate a progressive and see them lose
to trump or you could nominate a
progressive and see them defeat Trump
and become president you could also see
a centrist nominated and lose to Donald
Trump or you could see a centrist
nominated and defeat Donald Trump I want
to explore with you whether the best
outcome for the long term for
progressives might be that a centrist
like Joe Biden be nominated but lose to
Donald Trump in 2020 I've read some
articles about this over the last few
months and I want to think through the
scenarios with you let's first imagine
that a progressive is nominated but
loses to Trump in November this is bad
for the progressive movement because it
will be used not only by the right but
it'll even be used by the centrist
left to say look you got a shot you
nominated a progressive and they lost
this proves we can't move the party to
the left centrism and moderation and
trying to compromise with crazy
republicans is the path forward and that
could damage the left for a long time to
come next scenario would be that a
progressive is nominated and wins
defeats Donald Trump in 2020 in this
case that progressive would have to
govern with a likely Republican Senate
for at least two years if not more and
the serious possibility of losing
control of the house in the midterms as
often happens when you have a party
change in a presidential election the
next midterm the party that takes
control in the presidential loses
control of the house now none of that's
guaranteed but particularly with the
Republican Senate and especially if
Democrats lose control of the house in
2022 this would be a progressive
president who will undoubtedly fail to
accomplish many of their major campaign
promises and it would also be called a
major defeat for the progressive left
look you got someone in there and they
didn't do a damn thing Republicans will
take advantage centrist Democrats will
say look you won and you couldn't do
anything in 2022 and in 2024 and beyond
there are counter arguments and we'll
get to them later we're being thorough
here next possibility a centrist like
Joe Biden wins the nomination and
defeats Trump in 2020 now to a lot of us
this feels very unlikely myself included
but let's imagine that Biden is
nominated and wins this is of course
terrible for the progressive movement
because Joe Biden's not a progressive
this would allow the centrist Democrats
to claim the way to fight the right is
with a moderate like Joe Biden they'll
say look we nominated a centrist and a
centrist one they will say that's
evidence that progressivism is not the
way to go now Biden of course won't do
anything hugely progressive because he's
not a progressive and the center-left
will say this is the way to go this is
how you win with a centrist Democrat
that could also damage the progressive
movement for a long time so then we get
to scenario number four which again is
this the best game theory outcome
which is that Biden or another centrist
is nominated but they lose to Donald
Trump in November of 2020 in the long
term this might be the best for the
progressive movement number one it would
continue to provide support for the idea
that the way to beat the right is not
with a centrist because you'll have
Hillary having lost the Trump and Biden
having lost the Trump that's a real
strong case that it's really time for a
progressive a centrist would have been
nominated and lost again we would also
get another four years of an even more
unhinged and erratic Trump who no longer
has to run for re-election
who would likely be even crazier than
the Trump of the first term and this
might further justify supporting a true
progressive as the obvious and only way
to go in 2024 now of course that would
be a pretty bad four years for the
United States of America so I'm not here
to suggest we elect Joe Biden I'm not
voting for Joe Biden in the primary I'm
not here to suggest we allow Donald
Trump to win in 2020 what I'm presenting
to you from a game theory perspective is
the possibility that over the long term
the progressive left might benefit from
Biden being the nominee and losing to
Trump despite it being an absolutely
horrible outcome for the country in the
immediate now there are many counter
arguments to be made let's make some of
them one is a progressive president
elected in 2020 wouldn't lose the house
in 2022 nor would they suffer from a
Republican Senate the entire presidency
they might not get it in 2020 but they
could likely get it in 2022 and then
they could actually get some things done
they could put in place some of the most
significant progressive change in
history that's a possibility that would
be a counter argument that one could
make it would require a reversal from
historic trends but it is a completely
valid counter-argument to what I'm
suggesting another counter-argument
would be there are people who feel super
strongly that Bernie and Warren simply
would not lose to Trump and that they
would get a lot done let me know what
you think game it out with me and again
we're talking like adults here I'm
voting for a progressive and I'm voting
to defeat Donald Trump this is a con
that I'm having with you about the four
possible outcomes one of our sponsors is
privacy calm they're giving you $5.00
when you sign up for their completely
free service at privacy calm slash
Pakman I've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before it's a lifesaver
and here's how it works takes just a
couple of minutes to set up anytime you
buy something online or on the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them anytime you want so when you
do this it means you're not going to be
charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want privacy also
offers a $10 a month plan that gives you
one percent cashback and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a $25 a
month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create 60 card
numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with a free plan you'll protect
your financial info companies can't
charge you unexpectedly and like I said
you'll get $5 to spend when you sign up
at privacy calm slash Pakman